[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قضت المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا في مصر ببطلان الماده الثالثه من
قانون تقسيم الدوائر
الانتخابيه على اثر ذلك اعلن المتحدث باسم
اللجنه العليا ل خبات عن تاجيل انتخابات
مجلس النواب الى حين الانتهاء من دراسه
الحكم وقد كان مقررا لها ان تبدا في
الحادي والعشرين من الشهر الجاري نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل لقرار المحكمه الدستوريه علاقه
بحاله الاضطراب السياسي الذي تعيشه
مصر وهل يوفر تاجيل الانتخابات فرصه
لاعاده ترتيب الوضع السياسي في
البلاد
قانون انتخابات مجلس النواب القادم في مصر
باطل هذا ما خلصت اليه المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا وقد تسبب الحكم بعدم دستوريه
القانون في تاجيل انتخابات مجلس النواب
التي كانت مقرره في الحدي والعش من الشهر
الجاري ويطفي قرار تاجيل الانتخابات مزيدا
من الارباك على المشهد السياسي المصري
المرتبك اصلا ويفتح الباب لتساؤلات كثيره
ابرزها يتعلق بمصير خارطه الطريق التي وعد
بها السيسي في الثالث من يوليو تموز عام
2013 ولم تنجز بنودها حتى الان تقرير زياد
بركات
والمزيد ولا باس من كسب الوقت ايضا فثم
فراغ تشريعي ممتد عمليا منذ حل مجلس الشعب
في ابريل نيسان عام 2012 وها هي المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا تقضي بعدم دستوريه قانون
تقسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه ما يعني تاجيلات
خابات يستفيد منه رجل واحد في مصر تتركز
في يديه فقط السلطات كلها تقريبا عدم
دستوريه نص الماده الثالثه من قرار رئيس
الجمهوريه بالقانون رقم 202 لسنه
2014 في شان تقسيم دوائر انتخابات مجلس
النواب يكاد قانون تقسيم الدوائر
الانتخابيه الحالي يكون فريدا في العالم
كله فهو يخصص ثلث ث المقاعد للمرشحين على
النظام الفردي وما تبقى للقوائم المغلقه
ما يعني ضرب الاحزاب في مقتل وتهميش
حضورها في اي برلمان مقبل كما يفتح الباب
واسعا لتغ ما يوصف بالمال السياسي ويعيد
الى المشهد طرازا من النواب يوصفون بنواب
الخدمات فهم يفوزون في دوائرهم لا على
اساس برامجهم الانتخابيه بل على ما يعيدون
به ناخبيهم يستندون في ذلك الى ثرواتهم او
نفوذهم العائلي والقبلي ومن بين هؤلاء
كثير من رجالات مبارك يزيد الامر سوءا ان
يخصص الثلث المتبقي من مقاعد البرلمان
تقريبا لنظام القوائم المغلقه على ان تخصص
لها اربع دوائر انتخابيه فقط لتكون
النتيجه اضعاف قدره هؤلاء على التواصل مع
ناخبيهم وتقليل فرص التجانس بينهم في
البرامج واليات العمل
واستراتيجياته تحت قبه البرلمان لافت هنا
ان يكون قانون برلمان عام
اكثر تقدما من الحالي الذي كان يفترض ان
ينتخب البرلمان الجديد على اساسه ما يفسر
لدى البعض برغبه سياسيه لدى رعاه القانون
الحالي لاحكام قبضتهم على المؤسسه
التشريعيه والحيلوله دون وجود اي اغلبيه
قويه ومتماسكه فيها وذاك شان نظام يريد ان
يفرز نوابا يشكلون امتدادا له فقد سعى
مناصر السيسي الى تشكيل قوائم موحده
للترشيح لكنهم فشلوا كما وجهته عقبات اخرى
من قبيل طموح البعض السياسي معطوفا على ما
يتوفرون عليه من نفوذ ومال لانفاذ اجندات
سياسيه لا تتوافق تماما مع توجهات الرجل
فكان لابد من التاجيل لكسب الوقت على
الاقل واتاحه الفرصه لترتيب الاوضاع
وتكييفها قانونيا بما يخدم
توجهاته ينضم الينا في هذه الحلقه من
فرايبورج بسويسرا الدكتور او السيد حاتم
عزا نائب رئيس حزب الوسط وعضو مجلس الشعب
السابق ومن القاهره عبر سكايب السيد مجدي
درباله مدير تحرير صحيفه اخبار اليوم
المصريه مرحبا بكم هوسؤال للسيد حاتم عزام
بشمهندس حاتم ماذا يعني هذا القرار
بالنسبه لك تاجيل الانتخابات الى حين
الانتهاء من دراسه الحكم الصادر من
المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا تحياتي لحضرتك يا استاذ محمود
ضيفك الكريم وساده المشاهدين في مصر
والمنطقه العربيه كلها الحقيقه استاذ
محمود انا كتبت منذ فتره وقلت انه لن تجرى
انتخابات برلمانيه في مصر حتى لو مزوره
وحتى لو
مفصله وادعيت انه سيتم التاجيل وسيتم
التسويف ولن تجرى هذه الانتخابات وه قد
حدث رؤيتي في هذا الامر انه كل ما وحضرتك
اشرتم في التقرير على الى خريطه الطريق
الى ان كل ما تم من اجراءات بعد
3/7 وهكلم حضرتك بمنطق القابل بخريطه
الطريق انا طبعا لست قابل لهذه الخريطه
الطريق وارى ان هذا انقلابا عسكريا واضح
المعالم انما خلينا حتى نتحدث بمنطق خارطه
الطريق الذي اعلنه عبد الفتاح السيسي في
3/7 فان خريطه الطريق هذه كل ما وعد به
عبد الفتاح السيسي فيها لم يتحقق وكل ما
وعد انه لن يتحقق قد
تحقق يعني هناك اشياء انجزت ايضا يعني هو
تحدث عن انتخابات رئاسيه واجرى انتخابات
رئاسيه ربما فاز فيها لكن على الاقل هذا
الجزء من خريطه الطريق
حدث ا هو زي ما بقول لحضرتك هو هو كل ما
وعد به انه انه سيتحقق لم يتحقق وكل ما
وعد انه لن يتحقق قد تحقق بمعنى انه في
البدايه قال احنا ليس لنا طمع في الحكم
واشار انه هو شخصيا غير طمع في الحكم وانه
المؤسسه العسكريه لن تحكم
وا بعض القاده العسكريين زي احمد وصفي قال
انه المشير يعني لم يترقى ولم واذا لقيتوه
بقى رئيس جمهوريه او خد نجمه زياده يبقى
ده انقلاب ا واللي حدث ان هو بقى رئيس
جمهوريه فهو عمل كل الانقلاب ده عشان يبقى
رئيس جمهوريه الامر الاخر انه كل ما بقى
وعد به في خارطه الطريق من اشياء اخرى
زي حريه الاعلام وزي الوحده المجتمعيه وزي
الحقوق والحريات وزي كل شيء اخر لم يتحقق
حتى انه كل القوى السياسيه التي كانت
تنتمي لثوره 25 يناير والتي صدقت للحظه
انه هذا ليس انقلابا
وانه يعني سيقوم عبد الفتاح السيسي باعاده
الديمقراطيه الى مصر اللي استولى عليها
الاخوان المسلمين بحسب وجهه نظرهم عن طريق
انتخاب ديمقراطيه ا لم يفعل هذا وانا بقول
لحضرتك وانا يعني واضح في هذا لن تجرى
انتخابات برلمانيه في مصر وبالمناسبه هذا
ليس التاجيل الاول انا احيل حضرتك والساده
المشاهدين انه هذا التاجيل الثالث لانه
كان قد المفروض كانت تجرى هذه الانتخابات
حسب خريطه الطريق اولا قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ثم اجلت الى السته اشهر الاخيره
من العام الماضي او العام المنصرم 2014
ولم تجرى ثم اجلت مره اخرى الى اول ربع
الاول من 201
15 اخذ في العلم يا استاذ محمود دعني اطرح
السؤال على السيد مجدي درباله ساعود اليك
لاحقا بشمهندس حاتم دعني اطرح السؤال على
الاستاذ مجدي درباله استاذ استاذ
مجدي يعني البلد في مصر في مقبله على ختام
العام الثاني تقريبا منذ الثالث من يوليو
وحتى اللحظه الراهنه وهي بدون مؤسسه
تشريعيه
علم السياسه ينبئ ان الجميع في دائره
السلطه ونخبه الحكم يبحث عن مزيد من
السلطات باي شكل من الاشكال المستفيد
الوحيد من هذا الامر هو الذي بيده سلطه
التشريع في هذه
اللحظه هل يبدو لك هذا الكلام
منطقيا يعني بس دعني احييك واحيي المهندس
حاتم عزام بس عايز بس اذكره ببعض الاشياء
اذا كان يتحدث عن ان المؤسسه العسكريه او
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي قال ان مش هترشح
للح حكم ولا ليس لنا طمع وترشح اذا كان
الاستاذ حاتم يعني شايف ان ان المناورات
السياسيه ومثل هذه الكلمات فيها خطا
فتحالفوا الشرعيه بيدعم من هو فعل نفس
الشيء اخوان قالوا ليس لنا طمع في الحكم
مش مش ه نترشح وترشح الرئيس محمد مرسي
الرئيس السابق وهم بيدعمه دلوقتي اذا شايف
دهو خطيئه طب هو بيدافع ليه على على من
كان مرتكبا لمثل هذه الخطيئه من وجهه نظره
لكن ليس طرفا في اللعبه السياسيه لا يفترض
ان يكون وزير الدفاع والمؤسسه العسكريه
بصفه عامه طرفا في اللعبه السياسيه داخل
البلاد ما يجوز في حق الشخصيات السياسيه
عفوا سيد مجدي ما يجوز في حق الشخصيات
السياسيه لا يجوز في حق لواءات الجيش
والجنرالات
العسكريين يا ابي الوضع في في المنطقه
معقد من النهايه لابد ان يدرك الجميع انه
ليس هناك ثوابت سياسيه لان كل يوم في
تغييرات جديده كل يوم بتض مؤامرات جديده
وتحدث المهندس حاتم عزام على ان مؤيدي
ثوره 25 يناير في السجن هو السؤال هل هناك
من يشارك في ثوره ويحصل على سق انه لن
يمسه احد مهما ارتكب اي شيء طب ما هناك
المئات بل الالاف من مؤيدي ثوره 25 يناير
موجودين في كل الجهات حاليا منهم موجود في
احزاب منهم في وسائل الاعلام طيب هو مش
موضوعنا خلينا نعود خلينا نعود مجددا
للقانون او للقرار الذي صدر عن المحكمه
الدستوريه الياما تتب عليه من تركيز
للسلطات في يد الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
في هذه المرحله الحساسه والرجل لم يقصر
ولم يال جهدا في اصدار الكثير من
التشريعات في غياب البرلمان وهذا ما لم
يفعله مرسي عايز اقول لحضرتك حاجه هي
تشريعات مطلوبه وفي جزء منها تشريعات
سياسيه ومنها تشريعات اقتصاديه ومنها
تشريعات تخص الارهاب وحضرتك اعتقد ان
الجميع يرون ان مصر كانت في حاجه لمواجهه
الارهاب بقوانين رادعه اذا عدت لخريطه
الطريق لان حضرتك يعني انا متمسك بردك لان
حضرتك قلت ان هو بالفعل ملتزم بخريطه
الطريق وانا اذكر لا انا لم اق هذا انا
قلت ان بعض البنود التي جاءت في خريطه
الطريق وفي الوعد بها وبعضها لم يوفى
الوعد بشانها خريطه الطريق جاءت بعشر نقاط
انا انا اذكر جيدا خريطه الطريق التي
تلاها عبد الفتاح السيسي في الثالث من
يوليو عام
2013 هذا يعني في الاشاره الثانيه لاي
شخصيه سياسيه وانت تدري ذلك يشار الى
اللقب او يشار الى اس مجردا ه تنطق اسم
الامير مرق انطق اي اسم اي اسم رئيس اي
دوله في العالم سمعش اسم الامير بينطق
مجردا يا استاذ مجدي ارجوك خلينا في المهم
ارجوك دعنا نفاس الامور وترام رئيسي مده
الحلقه محدوده انا قلت الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي في بدايه الحلقه وفي الاشارات
التاليه عاده ما يفعل الاعلام هذا انت رجل
اعلام وتدري جيدا قال الرئيس فلان في
الاول وبعد كده فلان من غير الرئيس فيما
يلي مبارك قال مبارك عاد وهكذا ارجوك يعني
خلينا نركز على المهم من
الامور جاء في خريطه الطريق عش عشره بنود
ها من بينها بنود تراكم السلطه لدى فئه
معينه هذه تم الوفاء بها مثل انتخابات
الرئاسه مثل الازاحه بالرئيس المنتخب مثل
اداء اليمين الدستوريه
لل ل رئيس المحكمه الدستوريه رئيسا للبلاد
اما الاخرى المتعلقه بحق الشعب مثل ميثاق
شرف اعلامي ومثل العمل على الحفاظ على
الوحده الوطنيه وراب الصدع ومثل تحقيق
لجنه للمصالحه ومثل تشكيل برلمان منتخب
هذه لم تحقق حتى الان برغم مرور نحو عامين
على هذا الامر باختصار لو تك طيب انا بس
عايز اشوف في خلال العامين دول هل تم شيء
على ارض الواقع ام لا هل نسير نحو الطريق
الصحيح ام لا حضرتك قلت ان في دستور
بالفعل تم اقراره ان هناك رئيس تم انتخابه
ان هناك مجلس شعب يجري بالفعل الاعداد ليه
واعتقد يعني انا يعني استاذ المهندس حاتم
اتكلم قال لك لن يتم انتخاب مجلس الشعب طب
ماذا لو تم تم بعد شهر هل سيعتذر مهندس
حاتم عزام على الهواء هل ستعتذر يا بس
مهندس حاتم اذا تمت الانتخابات بعد شهر من
الان كما يقول السيد مجدي ديبال هل ستعتذر
عن توقعك الخاطئ ا الحقيقه الحقيقه خليني
اقول لحضرتك انا ليه بقول كده وهقول
لحضرتك انا هعمل ايه اولا ما كتبته منذ
حوالي اسبوع وصرحت به انه حاجتين انه لن
تجرى انتخابات برلمانيه في مصر وان اجريت
سيتم حل البرلمان لانه حضرتك يا ا يا
استاذ محمود هناك شيء معلوم بالضروره واضح
للعيان كلها في مصر للذي يريد ان يرى
الحقيقه انهه اولا من كان من استخدم كمعبر
وممر ل لتسليم السلطه لعبد الفتاح السيسي
في انتخابات غير نزيهه وغير ديمقراطيه اتت
على اعقاب انقلاب عسكري واضح هو كان رئيس
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا الذي عاد الى
مقاعده بعدما مارس دورا ا يعني ديكوريا
لكن حقيقه الامر كان من يدير الامور هو
وزير الدفاع الذي الجنرال الذي قام
بالانقلاب العسكري الان هذا رئيس المحكمه
الدستوريه عاد الى مقعده وقامت المحكمه
الدستوريه
بدورها المرتب سلفا لانه لا يعني لا
يستطيع ان يقتنع عقل انسان يا استاذ محمود
انه بلد تقعد ست شهور ولا 10 شهور بتعمل
قانون وتقول ان هو مش دستوري حتى قبل ما
تعمل انتخابات
طيب يعني هذه نقطه بالغه الاهميه هذه نقطه
بالغه الاهميه لكن اود ان اسالك استف ماذا
يضير السلطه الحال دعي حض اكمل السؤال
اللي سالته لي يعني ماذا يضير خلينا في
مهم المهم حول هذا الامر يعني عفوا عف
خلينا نركز على
موضوعنا ماذا يضر السلطه الحاليه ان جاءت
يعني ساجار فيما تفترضه ماذا يضر السلطه
الحاليه اذا جاءت
بانتخابات مثل التي حدثت في عام 2010
ويتشكل برلمان باكمله موالي للسلطه
الراهنه ماذا تقول في هذا هل تعجز السلطه
عن فعل
هذا لا هي السلطه تستطيع ان تفعل هذا وانا
بقول لك انه كان هناك رغبه فعلا ان يحدث
هذا وقد يحدث هذا بعد اشهر يعني كما ذكر
الاستاذ مجدي يعني سيتم تفصيل برلمان بعد
اشهر ما فيش مشكله ثم يحل مره اخرى لان
هناك سببا رئيسا لكل هذا اولا في محركين
المحرك الاول هو المؤتمر الاقتصادي في شهر
مارس الذي يدعو له ا
القائد عبد الفتاح السيسي قائد الانقلاب
العسكري هو دعى الى
مؤتمر كل الدول
المانحه وكل المؤسسات الماليه الضخمه التي
ستريد ان تعطي لمصر سكوك المصداقيه
الاقتصاديه لن تقوم بهذا الا بعد ان تكون
هناك مؤسسات منتخبه وتحديدا البرلمان وقد
اشترطت هذا في غير
مكان اما وان عبد الفتاح السيسي انا بقول
انه هو اكد من فشل هذا المؤتمر قبل
انعقاده قام بفعلين الفعل الاول هو
الهجمات الجويه على ليبيا والامر الثاني
انه اوقف
الانتخابات وهذه اشاره انه لا يامل اي شيء
من هذا المؤتمر الاقتصادي والا كان قام
بالانتخابات حتى بشكل صوري زي ما حضرتك
قلت الامر الثاني دائما اللي بيراود انه
هناك هناك نقطه خطيره جدا محتاج اقولها
لحضرتك انه حتى التعديلات الدستوريه التي
تم
على الدستور الشرعي للبلاد الذي استفت
عليه المصريين استفتاء مباشرا حرا
نزيها هذه التعديلات ولجنه ال 50 لم تنتبه
الى تغيير الفلسفه الرئيسيه التي قام
عليها هذا الدستور وهو فكره ان هناك رئيس
وزراء لا يستطيع رئيس الجمهوريه عزله
وبالتالي هنا هناك امر خطير الان انه قد
ينتج قد ينتج هناك احتمال ولو 10% 5% انه
ينتج ان هناك رئيس وزراء تبقى عنده سلطات
لا يستطيع السيسي عزله وبالتالي يمارس
صلاحيات طيب هذا الكلام يبدو متناقضا بعد
الشيء ان قلت ان السيسي او النظام الحاكم
يستطيع ان ياتي ببرلمان موالي تماما كما
حدث في 2010 ثم تقول انه يمكن ان ياتي
رئيس وزراء لا يستطيع الرئيس ان يعزله
سنناقش هذا بعد فاصل قصير معك ومع ضيفنا
الكريم الاستاذ مجدي درباله من القاهره
ولكن بعد فاصل قصير ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا
الاعزاء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش قرار المحكمه الدستوريه
في مصر ببطلان ماده في قانون تقسيم
الدوائر الانتخابيه ومن ثم تاجيل
الانتخابات البرلمانيه اعود بالسؤال الى
ضيفي من القاهره السيد مجدي
درباله باشمهندس حاتم عزام تحدث هنا عن
امكانيه اجراء هذه
الانتخابات يعني لاحقا في الفتره القادمه
لكنها ستاتي برلمان مشابه لبرلمان عام
2010 ثم عدد بعض الاسباب التي تشير الى
ا صدور هذا القرار في هذا التوقيت تحديدا
ما ردك يعني الاستاذ حاتم في الاول قال لك
اتحدى انها ستقام من الاساس لا بعد شهر او
غيره وعاد بعد ذلك ليؤكد انها لا ستعقد
وبتفصيل معين الصراحه انا شفت مجموعه من
التحليلات الاعلاميه والسياسيه حول
الانتخابات بعض الاعلاميين في مصر بداوا
يعطوا بعض الاتهامات لقضاه في المحكمه
الدستوريه بموالاتهم لجماعه الاخوان وانهم
ورا تاجيل الانتخابات التي لا يرغب الرئيس
في تاجيلها والبعض الاخر من الطرف الاخر
بدا يتحدث على ان الرئيس لا يرغب في اقامه
اي انتخابات ولكن الحكومه سرعان ما كان
لها اول رد فعل بعد صدور حكم المحكمه
الدستوريه بتاجيل الانتخابات واكدت انه لا
يوجد سوى شهر امام المؤسسات التي تتبع
الدوله لتعد قانون غير معيب يعني انا شفت
برض ردود فعل القوه السياسيه على على ما
حدث القوى السياسيه اكدت انه افضل بكثير
من ان تتكفل الدوله وان تنفق خمسه مليار
او من اثنين الى خ مليار جنيه تكلفه
للانتخابات ويشكك بعد ذلك في صحتها افضل
ان يتم التريث والنقاش حول النقاط او
الثغرات التي تحدثت عنها المحكمه
الدستوريه وهي بالمناسبه ثغره واحده تخص
مقاعد الفردي المحكمه الدستوريه يمكن عشان
الناس ممكن ما تعرفش قالت ان المقاعد ان
التقسيم الذي يخص المقاعد الفردي غير
مناسب لان القانون تم تشريعه لبعض
المحافظات ان ان يكون لكل كتله سكانيه
نائب وهذا غير متناسق مع المحافظات الاخرى
وطلبت بالعداله بغض النظر عن اعدا استاذ
مجدي هل تريد ان توحي بان قرارات المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا في مصر تصدر بمعزل عن
اللعبه السياسيه وبمعزل عن ضغوط السياسه
بينما قضاه المحكمه الدستوريه انفسهم
يقولون غير ذلك يقولون اننا ننصح المجلس
العسكري قالت هذا السيده تهاني الجبالي
عندما كانت نائبه في المحكمه المذكوره
وقالت اننا نصحنا المجلس العسكري بكذا
وكذا وكذا وتدخلات كلها في عالم السياسه
وقالت ان اعضاء المحكمه الدستوريه اسقطوا
البرلمان المنتخب انذاك لانه جاء باغلبيه
اسلاميه هذا ما ذكرته لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز عايز اقول لحضرتك حاجه تاني الجبالي
كذبه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وتحدث كذبت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ونيويورك تايمز سخرت
من تكذيبها هذا وقالت اننا لسنا مجانين
حتى نفك حوارا مثل هذا مع قاضيه بهذا
المستوى في مصر وبصحي مثل حجم يعني حجمها
او وجودها مثل نورك تايمز والسيده
تجبي السيده تهاني الجبالي وعدت بقاض
الصحيفه ولم نسمع ان الصحيفه قضي عليها او
حكم عليها باي شيء سيدي الكريم انا لو
عايز اعدد لحضرتك اخطاء واشنطن بوست
ونيويورك تايمز المهنيه ممكن بس اعتقد
المجال لن يتسع عندك هناك اخطاء جسيمه تخص
فبركه اشياء بالكامل وادعاء اقامه حوارات
مع اشخاص لم يت مجدي احنا بنتكلم عن اكبر
صحيفتين في العالم نورك تايمز وواشنطن
بوست
قامت امامها مظاهرات من المصريين واتهموها
بالارهاب بتمويل الارهاب ودعم الارهاب
يعني عايز اقول لحضرتك لا لو اتكلمت على
على العدم عدم المهنيه لا هناك اخطاء
كثيره ولكن هذا ليس موضوعنا حضرتك بتتحدث
عن انعزال قضه المحكمه الدستوريه عن
السياسه ويمكن قبل حضرتك الاستاذ حاتم
تحدث على ان رئيس المحكمه الدستوريه كان
رئيسا للجمهوريه واستجاب رئيس المحكمه
الدستوريه اصبح رئيسا للجمهوريه مؤقتا
بحكم القانون انه في حاله غياب الرئيس ان
رئيس المحكمه مجلس الشعب رئيس المحكمه
الدستوريه هو اللي بيقوم هذا الدور اي
قانون يصنع هذا يعني كان هناك دستور
للبلاد يتحدث عن خطوات معينه ومحدوده لعزل
الرئيس ليس من بينها تدخل القوات المسلحه
ولا تدخل وزير الدفاع للاطاحه به والاتيان
برئيس المحكمه الدستوريه العليا اي قانون
تتحدث عن ماذا حدث وماذا حدث في 25 يناير
هل هناك
تنظيم احنا بنشتغل قانون ولا بنشتغل ثوره
ثوره طب ماهو ثوره و 30 يونيو ثوره حضرتك
عايز تقارن ممكن اقارن لحضرتك عناصر
الثوره هتقول انقلاب ما برض بعض الناس
اتهموا 25 يرنا انقلاب يعني اذا كنت يعني
انا انا لا انحس لاي فكره من من
ال عفوا ساعود اليك لاحقا استاذ مجدي
بشمهندس حاتم اذا صدر يعني حسبما يقول
ضيفنا من القاهره الاستاذ مجدي درباله ان
قرار المحكمه الدستوريه صدر بنزاهه تامه
وحياه تام ومحدد في ملاحظاته على هذا
القانون ما
ردك انا عايز اصحح بس جزء لانه اتمنى من
ضيفك الكريم انه لا يبتسم ما اقول انا قلت
بشكل واضح وهو يعود الى هذا قبل اسبوع
وكتبته على صفحتي الشخصيه وصرحت بيه في
برنامج في قناه الشرق مع الاستاذ معتز
وقلت انه لن تجرى انتخابات برلمانيه وان
تمت وان اجريت سيتم حل البرلمان بعدها انا
قلت الاثنين مع بعض لم اناقد نفسي وما زلت
اقولها اما عن الاسباب ليه لن يا سيدي
الفاضل يعني دعك انه يعني صحيفه الواشنطن
بوست تماه للارهاب وتدعم الارهاب وانا
سعيد الحقيقه انه يعني صحيفه الاخبار تبقى
افضل من اتمنى يعني ان صحيفه جريده
الاخبار التي يراس تحريرها الاستاذ الضيف
الكريم تبقى احسن من الواشنطن بوست اتمنى
هذا كمصر يعني لكن هذا ليس واقع الحال
انما ليس ادل عن انه المحكمه الدستوريه ا
يعني تمارس السياسه حتى اخمس قدميها الا
انه لم يجد عبد الفتاح السيسي معبرا الى
تسليمه كرسي الرئاسه سو رئيسها في حين انه
كل وكما كما راينا التسريبات التي اثبتت
صحتها مؤسسه جي بي اسوشيتس في انجلتره
ونشر في جريده الاندبندنت الانجليزيه انه
هذه التسريبات صحيحه فقد راينا كيف يتعامل
وزير الدفاع ويقود كل شيء في البلد بما
فيه القانون والدستور في فتره وجود عدلي
منصور دي نمره واحد فده دليل دامغ على
فكره انه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا ما هي
الا فكره الا المطاط الذي يحتاجه قائد
الانقلاب ايض وجيهه يعني الوقت ربما لا
يتسع ل الاسترسال في بس انا انا ارجو ان
حك تديني فرصه اكمل اه اكمل ليه بقى عبد
الفتاح السيسي لا يريد ان يفعل هذا لانه
يريد ان يمسك بكل السلطات في يده هو
يشعر يعني انه لم ينجز داخليا سياسيا
واقتصاديا واجتماعيا ويخاف من المحاسبه
لانه مدان الان بجرائم ضد الانسانيه وخاف
من المحاكمه والمسه قانونيه ثم انه ثم انه
استاذني يا دكتور محمود القت محدود للغايه
ما فيش وقت يا مس حاتم عفوا ارسل في 30
ثانيه ما هو ما فيش 30 ثانيه للاسف هوخ
التشريعات المقيده للحريات استاذ مجدي
درباله القانون المعيب الذي حكمت المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا ببطلان ماده فيه هو من
صنع عبد الفتاح السيسي نفسه الرئيس السيسي
نفسه اصدر هذا القانون العام الماضي ثم من
يتحمل فاتوره التاجيل بهذه الصوره لماذا
لم يستشر اهل الخبره واهل القانون لكي
يصدر قانونا متماسكا سليما اولا نقطه نقطه
سريعه انا مدير التحرير مش رئيس تحرير
اخبار اليوم حضرتك عبد الفتاح السيسي اقر
القانون مش وليس رجل قانون لاحظ انك تقول
عبد الفتاح السيسي من غير رئيس يعني انت
تقول يا سيدي هاشم انا بستقوي المعلومه من
حضرتك تفضل كان هناك خبراء للاسف وقعوا في
خطا وهذا الخطا قد يكون متكرر لما حدث في
2012 لان ما حدث في 2 12 مجلس شعب كان
هناك في خطوات معيبه وتم التحذير منها
وكان هناك من يتوقع بس احنا ما وقعنا في
غلطه 2012 انه رغم التحذيرات تمت
الانتخابات وحصلت ان في فاتوره كبيره
دفعها الشعب ورغم ذلك تم ابطال المجلس
المره دي الح هناك فاتوره اخرى ايضا
يدفعها الشعب من وقته بالبقاء بدون مؤسسه
تشريعيه انا اشكركما شكرا جزيلا السيد
مجدي درباله مدير تحرير صحيفه اخبار اليوم
المصريه كان معنا من القاهره عبر سكايب
ومن فرايبورج بسويسرا اشكر ضيفنا الدكتور
حاتم عزام المندس حاتم عزام نائب رئيس حزب
الوسط وعضو مجلس الشعب السابق واشكركم
مشاهدينا الاعزاء بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
تعالى في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله